it's a Thursday which you know means we
don't have much time it never feels like
we have much time but even more so on
days like today so let's get started
hopefully you're most the way to getting
is don't worry it'll stay on screen for
a little bit but not forever and there
will be other notes to write down as
well I wonder if you can think back to
our last lesson we were having a look at
measures of central tendency remember
those guys right there were three of
them and we've covered two so far right
we covered mode
it was just like highest probability on
your distribution and we covered what
was the second one mode and median right
remind me to come back to that at the
end of this will we have a few more
things to say about that but may medians
done now we're talking about mean right
that's that's the third and final
measure of central tendency that we're
interested in now as with all things
these measure central tendency are so
much easier when you just have like a
bunch of scores right it's like here's
the people who scored five here's the
ones who scored ten etc you just want
let's think about how you calculate a
mean when you have this kind of
information right number one you just
take all of the scores that are in your
data set and then you multiply them by
something what do you multiply by think
we're trying to find the mean right
I'm multiplied by the the number of
times of that thing happens we have a
name for that that's of an F the
frequency thank you so we take these
guys right the scores and we multiply by
the frequency right so you can read that
chart yourself you can see where the
heights got to be just for convenience
I've put the numbers there so we take
each score multiplied by frequency but
then we have to do one more thing to
actually get the main we've multiplied
so now we divide right so we divide by
where this number come from
seven but I get it from it's how many
scores I have in my distribution so one
plus three plus two plus one gives me
that seven and then off you go I mean
you can go ahead and verify that I
didn't get this wrong my calculator but
you get a value out of that right and
you have a look at the scores that you
got this 12.1 for this look about right
like yeah most of the scores I mean 10
is the mode and you've got more down
this end than you have
that in so that's why you you sort of
you're mean gets dragged up making sense
so far okay good so this is with a
frequency distribution I wonder if you
can think back to bivariate data no
sorry I take it back we actually looked
at this I'm just descriptive statistics
when we take a frequency distribution
and kind of like translate it into a
probability distribution I want you to
think about your graph and how it would
look different there's not much of a
change if you were to take that same
data and make it a probability
distribution have a think about it for a
second you won't have frequency anymore
will you because you're like I don't
know how many there are all I know is
the probability of each one right so
instead of having one two three going up
on your vertical axis you're not going
to have that quantity you're instead
going to have well I want a probability
distribution so you can have
probabilities does that make sense okay
why are they all out of seven because
that's how many they were before but
it's worth pointing out like it could've
been 70 or 700 and I would just have
more in each groups so this is just our
relative frequencies that make sense
okay excellent so let's think about how
we get the equivalent the mean out of
this write the equivalent measure of
central tendency I can do the same thing
and start with the scores right but I
then hit a snag because I can't multiply
by frequency anymore can I
because because I don't know what the
frequency is right so what I multiply by
instead well the equivalent thing right
is the probability that's what the
vertical axis tells you now right so if
I were to take these scores here sorry
these probabilities here I then just
multiply each one sort of like I did
before now I tried to color code this to
make it a little clearer to you but I
hope without even getting a calculator
out you can anticipate this is going to
give you exactly the same answer that we
got before does that make sense right
now just to make it really painfully
obvious for you right and I'd love you
to have this written down because we
going to refer to it in a second just
have a look at the two calculations
side-by-side this is us working out the
mean on a frequency distribution yes
this is us working out on a probability
distribution but but like look right
they are the same thing like you can see
whole thing's been divided by 7 which is
the same as dividing H 1 by 7
individually which is your priorities
make sense now despite the fact that we
get the same value for H 1 right because
this guy's on a probability distribution
we'd give it an ever so slightly
different name I wonder if anyone
remembers what it's called it's not
called the mean anymore it's about yeah
it's about well if this is your
distribution right like what value would
you anticipate that you get if you did
this experiment over and over again
right what value would you anticipate we
call it starts with an E I think back
expected it's expected value right and
we denote it with an e for expected
right see you're very close ok so this
is what it looks like in a concrete
situation but of course we're always
interested in like generalizing out like
what does this look like for any set of
data right so I want you to have a look
again at the two things that get added
up over and over and over again right
what are these black numbers again black
numbers here they're they're the scores
that you could score in this in this
test or whatever right and then the
colored things are the probabilities
right so score probability score
probability and then you just take all
those and you add them on remember this
notation right add up the products of
your scores and probabilities okay it's
causing probabilities now all of this as
we've seen before this is in a situation
where you have specific scores like you
can get five you can't get you know in
between five and ten right so we should
say that this is for a discrete
distribution right a discrete random
variable but that's not that a territory
we've been in over the last couple of
weeks right we've been looking at not
discrete we're gonna get continuous
random variables right so I want you to
think about how would you translate this
idea taking a sum of different things
which is discrete into a continuous
context what would that look like what
do we do instead of adding up individual
chunks we we add up all these little
bits we have a name for this right
adding up all these little bits and
putting them all together we call it we
spent a whole topic on it guys starts
with an i we call the integration right
so that big Sigma notation is going to
turn into an in
in a continuous random variable and this
stuff on the right hand side well it's
gonna look like that's core times the
probability density function does this
make sense right for that probability
we're not gonna have like this one in
that one we're gonna have this changing
value over time but I hope that you can
see even though this looks a lot more
like involved it's really the same thing
right it's just that in a continuous
context you got to deal with the
integrals not with just sums of nice
neat chunks